Hello world,
it's Saroj and I'm going to show you
how to ace any data science interview in
five steps. If you're new here, welcome,
subscribe to stay updated on
my latest technology videos,
I've now been on both ends
of the hiring pipeline.
I've gotten lots of rejections,
I've gotten offers and I've hired people
that data science interviewing game is
not easy.
You sit across the table from someone
who has the power to grant you income and
a measure of security.
You have to make them like you,
trust you and think you're smart.
That can be kind of scary,
but luckily it's been proven that with
dedicated practice you can master this
field. The top data scientists
in the world are made not born.
So let's start with the first step.
Figure out what you want.
Getting a data science
job is a huge life change,
so it's important to ask yourself
why you want to be in this field.
Take some time to be
introspective, meaning deeply
reflect on your own thoughts,
feelings,
and sensations in order to gain insights.
It's a rare quality in
our fast paced society,
but it allows you to keep focused on
the bigger picture and clearly define
happiness on your own terms.
Happiness is a warm GPU also followed
popular investors to gain insights on
industry trends.
It's literally their job to figure out
how technology is transforming different
industries and the opportunities in them.
Venture capital firms like Andreessen
Horowitz have their own podcasts where
they talk about the future
in terms of economic trends.
Find top angel investors and
vcs on Twitter and follow them.
Their insights can inspire you and I've
got a curated list for you that I'll
link to in the video description along
with any other resources I'll mention
later on.
There are so many different
data science roles out there.
Every company seems to have their own
requirements and definitions for the
positions they're hiring for,
so it's hard to get a
general understanding of how
they're different and have
the skills they require.
Use Google's job search feature to read
through the various job descriptions in
each field to get more familiar with the
type of role you'd find most rewarding.
Listen to day in the life interviews with
data scientists on podcasts like data
stories.
You can use all of these data points to
help you build a five year career plan.
Having a longer term plan will help
you feel more confident, motivated,
and give you insight into what
skills you'll need to learn,
which brings us to step two,
create and execute a study plan.
Once you know what you want to do with
data science and why you need to ensure
your skill set is up to date data science
professionals need a wide range of
skills including knowledge of statistics,
the linear Algebra,
programming, databases and
communication. Luckily for you,
I just released a video that details a
free three month curriculum meant to help
you go from absolute beginner
to proficient in data
science in three months.
I also want to give a special
shoutout to Chromebook data science.
It's a collection of 12 courses offered
by John Hopkins University at you can
take for free to help people
with no background and
limited resources transition
into data science and one more open
source society university has a detailed
path to a free self taught education in
data science that's listed in the form
of a good hub. Read me that you
should definitely check out as well.
It's very comprehensive.
Once you've consumed these free resources,
you'll want to practice actual technical
interviews using interviewing.io.
Anyone can practice a technical interview
anonymously with real hiring managers
at places like Google and Microsoft for
free practice makes perfect and you even
get feedback as well.
Flashcards are another great
tool to help you learn faster.
It's important to retain all of the
technical terms like classification and
principal component analysis as you'll be
asked about them during your interview.
Brainscape has several existing free
flashcards for a wide variety of data
science subjects.
Make reciting these definitions.
Second nature to you like riding
a bike or skipping you to me ads.
You want to get into the mind of an
interviewer. Put yourself in their shoes.
What kind of questions
would you ask candidates?
Write down those questions.
This thought experiment will help you
better relate to your interviewers and
become a better interviewee as well.
In total,
this entire study plan should take between
three to five months and learning all
of this on your own.
We'll do a lot for you,
but having an experienced mentor to help
guide you during this journey would be
incredibly valuable as well.
Look through your existing social
network and see if you know anyone who's
worked in a data science role.
Reach out to them and see if they
would be willing to help you along your
journey with any questions you might have.
If you frame it as a two way
learning session meeting,
you're offering them something as well,
you'll have much better results. Also,
sharpest minds is a dope resource.
They'll provide you with a data science
mentor that's free upfront and the way
you pay them back is by giving them
five to 10% of your first year's income.
If you land a job companies,
especially in Silicon Valley,
we'll post a job online and get 500 to
a thousand applications in the first
couple of days. It's hard to
get prioritized in this queue.
So ideally you want them to reach out
to you and the best way to do that is to
build your portfolio.
That means first having an amazing resume
and I've got a great video on that for
you.
It's important to have not one but at
least three different types of resumes
each tailored to the different
types of positions you like.
Perhaps one is more suited for a
data science position in finance,
showcasing finance
keywords like time series,
forecasting and sentiment analysis,
while another is more suited
for a position in medicine,
highlighting your image
classification skills. Additionally,
have a well crafted personal website
that showcases your past projects and any
relevant education or work history.
Think of your personal website like a
more visually appealing version of your
resume.
Link to all of your social channels,
aggregate everything about you onto it
and of course keep your get hub profile,
the new resume up to date
with at least three projects.
All of them should be well documented,
have at least one project
with a web presence.
You want this project to be
easily accessible to anyone.
If they can try out your Twitter
sentiment classifier themselves,
there'll be much more likely to hire you.
Create educational content
around data science as well,
be at blogs or even get up to [inaudible].
This will build your following
and bring you more opportunities.
Once you've studied and
position your brand well,
it's time to start pitching for
potential jobs. Use Angel List.
Ask Your friends on
social media who's hiring.
Connect with venture capital firms to
see if any of their newer portfolio
members are hiring.
A packer news has a hiring thread.
Find interesting industries that don't
have as much of a data science presence
like agriculture or manufacturing
and find jobs in that sector.
Put in the hard creative work to find
positions other candidates aren't thinking
about. Add all of these companies
to an excel spreadsheet.
It's important to keep track
of where you're applying to.
You need to stay organized.
If you're talking to 30 or 40 companies,
you shouldn't keep track
of them using MS paint.
It should be in a spreadsheet rate.
Each of these companies based on your
interest level, take any notes on them,
their URL and their job posting.
Keep track of your progress at each stage
of the interview process including the
pitch, the phone screen, the coding
challenge, and the onsite interviews.
Each of these companies have a gatekeeper,
usually the technical recruiter you need
to win over the recruiter to get to the
phone screen. The best way to source
these technical recruiters is linkedin.
You can easily find recruiters on
linkedin for a specific position using a
little bit of Google keyword magic,
contacting technical recruiters directly
rather than cold emailing a company's
default job's email. We'll give
you a much better response rate.
You want to stand out
so when you pitch them,
they'll probably give your
email 10 seconds of attention.
So make sure to have a quick intro that
sells yourself impressively in a few
sentences. Name, background,
easily digestible project and
an interest to learn more.
Make it easy for them.
I use Calendly to let people schedule
meetings with me at a given time.
I found it cuts down the logistics
to schedule things by a lot,
so include that in your pitch.
Also,
one way to really stand out is to do a
data science project for a company that
solves a problem for them without
even being asked to do so.
It is of course a risky time investment,
so I'd recommend only doing this for the
three positions that interest you the
most. Once you've got your
first phone screen scheduled,
it's time for the last step,
the interview process you can find and
practice company specific interview
questions on glass store before your
interviews to brush up on their specific
hiring process.
Generally,
the data science job interview
involves three different steps. First,
the phone screen with a recruiter or
someone from HR or a hiring manager.
This is a way for them to get to know you,
your background,
and it's a way for you
to get to know them,
their culture and why they'd
be a good fit for you.
Next is the coding challenge.
It could be either take home or a live
coding challenge where an interviewer
watches you code either on a
whiteboard or on a computer screen.
The language is usually your choice,
but expect to code in python or
SQL or both. If it's in Mat lab,
just walk out.
Just kidding.
A company will sometimes
give you a version of their
Dataset to solve a problem,
meaning they could ask you to find out
features that led to increased viewership
and show them the code for
how you made those insights.
Live coding challenges can last up to
two hours while take home assignments can
last up to 48 hours.
Once you've passed both of these,
it's time for the onsite interview.
Usually this is with the team lead and
it consists of a mix of technical and
behavioral questions.
Expect questions that range the full
stack from the difference between
supervised and unsupervised learning.
Two types of sequel queries to use to
business scenario problems to logic based
questions and expect several rounds
with a wide variety of people including
people from sales,
marketing and product development.
This could take a full day.
If you get a question that
you don't know the answer to,
you can still get points for
knowing the nature of the problem.
You can say something like,
I'm not sure the best way to solve this,
but let me write out some ideas that
I have and ways I could go about doing
this.
This way they can watch your thought
process if you've seen the problem before,
you can just say, I seen it before and
they'll pass on to the next problem.
Companies are looking to hire
talented data scientists,
also people they enjoy working with.
They want to see that you have
legitimate curiosity around data science,
that you're passionate about,
the problem they are trying to solve
and that you're able to communicate your
thought process. Even though data
science uses statistics and coding,
it's more than that.
You have to get people to buy into what
you're doing and why you're doing it.
By communicating to both technical
and nontechnical audiences.
That's a crucial skill to have.
They are investing in you financially,
emotionally, and psychologically.
If you want an edge,
research your interviewer beforehand,
find out their interests,
understand their background,
then mention something that's a genuine
mutual interest for both of you during
the interview.
It'll increase their sentiment
towards you and after each interview,
definitely follow up with
a thank you note. Remember,
make everyone's job easier.
One last point.
It's okay to get rejections.
It's easy to internalize your performance
in these interviews as an overall
reflection in your abilities as a data
scientist and even as your worth as a
human.
Don't take any rejection personally,
but instead as feedback
along your journey,
if you keep the larger
picture in perspective,
by having a longterm plan and being
dedicated to mastering this craft,
you'll eventually find your place.
I'm here for you.
We are here for you.
Your success is our success.
So keep your head up and
if you do land a job,
share it with me on social media using
these school of Ai Careers Hashtag so I
can help promote your
success to inspire others.
What's been your experience
with data science interviews?
Let me know in the comments
section, please subscribe
for more technology videos.
And for now, I've got to hire an
intern, so thanks for watching.